hi everyone good afternoon and welcome
my name is priyamvadajan I'm an
astrophysicist with strong intellectual
interests in the history and philosophy
of science and I serve as the current
director of Yale's Flagship
interdisciplinary Frankie program in
science and the humanities
it's my absolute pleasure today to start
this wonderful event by first
recognizing our benefactors Mr and Mrs
Richard and Barbara Frankie thanks to
their generosity this program and many
other initiatives at Yale have benefited
from their Vision to Foster scholarship
that breaks disciplinary boundaries and
generates radical new lenses to view the
world through
meanwhile before we start today's event
I am required to give you this notice
this event is being recorded and
photographed for educational archival
and promotional purposes including use
and print on the internet and other
forms of media by attending this event
today you agree to the possibility of
your voice or your likeness captured by
these means and used for such purposes
without compensation to you and hereby
wave any related right to privacy or
publicity
so uh before I introduce our fantastic
speaker this evening let me remind you
that we have a reception upstairs after
the talk in the student lounge
immediately after the event so you're
all invited to please come join us
there's some really yummy food there so
now on to today's event
I can promise you it'll be a real treat
this evening we are gathered for a book
talk by one of our own the incredible
mind whom we are fortunate to have on
our faculty at Yale professor jinsu
Professor sue the John M Schiff
professor of East Asian languages and
literatures and comparative literature
at Yale is a cultural historian literary
scholar of modern China at Yale
University the first tenured professor
appointed in East Asian languages and
literatures and comparative literature
her research spans literature
Linguistics Science and Technology
internationalization regionalization
regionalism sorry and globalization and
U.S China relations she's a member and
former chair
2014-2021 of the Council on East Asian
studies and a senior research fellow at
the MacMillan Center for international
and area studies and an affiliate
faculty at the Jackson School of global
affairs
um Professor Sue has written for the New
York Times New York Times book review
the financial times and has author or
co-edited five books her most recent
book uh which brought is what we're
going to be hearing about today Kingdom
of characters the language Revolution
that made China modern was named among
the hundred notable books of 2022 by the
New York Times and the best non-fiction
of 2022 list in the Washington Post it's
been reviewed extensively pretty much
every major publication has reviewed it
across across the world including the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
Financial Times the New Yorker Economist
wired science nature the guardian times
literary supplement London Review of
Books and the South China Morning Post
and of course the NRC in Holland and the
and the Frankfurter element in Germany
this book tells the story of how China
and its language entered the information
age dominated by the Western Alpha a bit
in Spring 2023
jinxu is delivering Yale's William Clyde
Devane lectures China in six keys
Jing is widely recognized for her
original approach interdisciplinary
synthesis and perspective on China she
has held fellowships and honors from
multitude a multitude of places
including the Society of fellows at
Harvard the Woodrow Wilson Foundation
the center for advanced studying the
Behavioral Sciences at Stanford the
Alexander Bond Humboldt Foundation the
Ratcliffe Institute new directions
Fellowship from the melon foundation and
the institute for advanced study and the
John Simon Guggenheim Foundation
I don't need to tell you this she's an
extremely distinguished scholar whose
work
we are really excited to hear more about
uh before we start the event and I
invite Jing to the stage um I want to
mention a couple of our ongoing projects
and upcoming events so we have a
learning by doing project which is we
are collecting little simple science
videos of little experiments that can be
done at home for children from around
the world who can do little experiments
just to fulfill their curiosity so if
you would like to be a contributor and
send in a video please go ahead and take
a look at our website we would be
delighted the next announcement I want
to make quick one is next Wednesday at 4
pm we have a film screening of the Lost
Leonardo followed by a full post film
moderated discussion with Diane
modestini the famed art conservator
whose restoration work actually led to
the discovery of the of the artwork and
was critical in establishing that it was
a Leonardo so yeah please mark your
calendars next Wednesday at 4 pm and on
Tuesday April 18th we have another
wonderful book talk by one of our own
Professor Beverly Gage who will be
talking to us about her recent book
G-Man J Edgar Hoover and the making of
the American Century
and on April 26th we have we carry a
world within US Cellular structures that
allow us to live in a very hostile
environment I want to often read out
these quiz to show you that how
interdisciplinary the offerings are so
please mark your calendars and I look
forward to seeing you at many of these
events
so um it's a particular pleasure for me
as Jing also happens to be a close
friend so without further Ado Jing the
floor is yours thank you so much for
coming
thank you very much Priya um I have to
first thank the Frankie program for
having me today I'm not sure of any talk
I can deliver can live up to that very
generous introduction from Priya but as
you know we're friends
in any case it's a delight to be here I
feel that is long overdue since the book
came out a year ago and I think also
Alice Kaplan
um director of humanity Center last year
with human Center who invited me to come
speak
so today as I've given a lot of talks on
this book I thought I share with you
here in some ways the the path that led
me to it that's why it's called behind
Kingdom characters in some ways and I'll
take you through this particular thread
in the book
there's really three
points of Genesis
and one actually brings me back to my
roots as a literary scholar as a student
of monotoni's literature any student
will have read all the writings if not
most by this man who should
he was a proponent of using vernacular
speech to replace on the elite literary
classical Chinese in the early 20th
century
this was a movement that really
revolutionized in modern China because
it gave language back to the people the
power of literacy and this is really the
beginning of it
but of all the things that you would
read by Hoshi there's this one here
that's often unnoticed and it took me
years until I embarked in this book to
realize that all the evidence and the
cues were there I just didn't quite see
it when I was strictly a student of
literature
so this is a
pretu this um this scheme on Chinese
characters which I will talk about in a
bit
he talks about of all things not
vernacular versus Elite language but the
idea of organization
and he says here to order is to find a
logical threat in chaos and here he's
actually commenting on this immense task
that Chinese were faced with in the
early 20th century how do they actually
preserve and hold on to the written
Heritage given that there's an onslaught
of westernization and a pressure
monetization that was basically making
old knowledge seem old and unpopular and
very kind of a um calcified
but then when he talks about the he said
it was really important the hard task is
really this very pedestrian very mundane
thing to do which is to make sure that
you can find things where you find them
and that is tedious for sure and he
talks about how this is really kind of
like a service industry part of modern
Chinese literature that there's going to
be people who will have to do it and
they will be like the saviors and
martyrs for literature
himself
although he will support them they said
people who engage in this kind of
painstaking labor do it so that other
people don't have to
and so regardless
oh sorry I'm not sure why this
just fell out
is it coming out great sorry no no you
see what I'm reading from so
sorry for the momentary blindness so
regardless of what these what people do
the scholarly world is utterly indebted
to them
so it's this group of people that I got
very interested in who is this this this
this invisible community that managed to
carry modern Chinese literature the very
language that made up literature on
their backs but who went utterly
recognized and you know as USA said
they're basically doomed to anonymity
so that was my first thread right there
my first clue and I tucked this away in
my mind
and about 10 years ago when I was
working into the history of Science and
Technology I decided to educate Myself
by reading Joseph Needham's this very
famous seminal works by Joseph Needham
called the science science and
civilization in China
it was about 26 volumes don't worry I
didn't get through all of them
26 volumes and Jose Dino was a towering
figure
and in 1956 a volume 2
he made these references in footnotes
about the Chinese language they can see
that this is where this towering mind at
the time he had doubts about the
fundamental task he was undertaking
which is to justify and explain how
China had always had Science and
Technology right to refute the fact that
just because science the Scientific
Revolution took place in the west
doesn't mean that China didn't have
their own accomplishments scientific and
technological
but he had a doubt when it came to the
language
and he said
he will quote other people in these
footnotes and say well some people say
that something about the Chinese
language that hampers through thinking
right that kind of skews the way or
limits the way or charts a particular
way of thinking because of the character
idiographic writing system they had
but clearly he had doubts because he did
not put that in the main body and there
was yet another footnote that says well
Chinese seem particularly
um
well positioned to think combinatory
logic by virtue of the fact that
character writing are made of Parts
rather than alphabetic letters that kind
of in a linear linear rollout
so that was my second clue and I kind of
wonder about that is it true at a time
is it true that alphabetical thinking
the alphabetic mind in some ways was
um more amenable to modernization was it
more Superior was it more accessible was
it easier than idiographic thinking or
thinking in the Chinese character
language
and of course when I looked into the
literature and the scholarship the
history that I've been written in my
field it wasn't very helpful because
whenever we talk about Chinese language
it was very much framed cast in a frame
of ah superiority versus inferiority
the infuriation of Chinese language and
culture and the way that we put them as
primitive or more backwards as opposed
to Western civilization right which is
actually a relatively recent hierarchy
that happened in 19th century with your
Revolution evolution
and so I looked in other places hoping
that there were other disciplines that
could give me a clue
and this is around 2015 where I then
came across a subfield in Neuroscience
which was a study this this the the
Neuroscience of reading
so writing system you know we might not
think about this is actually very young
it basically developed within a blinking
eye in in the larger shape of evolution
right about five thousand years they
found 5500 years old
so it's not really possible that
evolutionarily we could have adapted our
brain's got adapt it so quickly that we
have a particular set of neurons that
just deal with writing
so it turns out they're built on a more
a prior infrastructure of pattern
recognition
of identifying you know where the
Horizon meets with their intersections
and the roads you will also know that
when you look at an expansive ocean you
know normally you normally fix your gaze
somewhere right so that's what we're
kind of fine-tuned for evolutionary
purposes so that we can find our way
home after we you know hit that tiger of
the head or or deer we try to carry it
back to our caves so so it makes a lot
of sense
and it took me to Marina del Rey to
visit a neuroscientist who were the
first to talk about pattern recognition
and human the visual image processing
Urban beaterman whom actually I was sad
to find out just the other day that he
passed away in 2022
and so this train of thought then led me
down another rabbit hole but it turns
out according to neuroscientists they're
different ways and different startup
costs for reading the alphabet or
reading either graphic writing but
eventually it all comes out pretty much
the same right literacy and literacy we
learn to accustom and to connect
patterns in such a way that they become
conventionalized and internalized and
that's when we read them
so this is kind of bottom line but I was
still not quite satisfied
so what is it about the Chinese language
that's been so domestic that's so
mystified for centuries that baffled the
Western missionaries since
the 16th century that have given rise to
accusations and assumptions of
inferiority of of what health what held
the Chinese back in the 20th century so
on and so forth the criticism was not
just coming from westerners themselves
but also the Chinese they too came to
see mainly because of their interaction
with the Western alphabet how cumbersome
in some ways how unfriendly the Chinese
language was to modernity
so it was my goal then to set on set out
to prove or to figure out is that really
true and if so why
and there's also more direct route to
this because when I was working on my
last book in 2010 sound and script in
Chinese diaspora one of my favorite
writers Lee Tong turned out his lifelong
passion was to build a Chinese
typewriter
at the time I didn't know what to make
of this and quite just a point of course
as a student of literature you imagine
these writers just locked themselves
away in an attic and to you know listen
to their Muse and right away but he had
a very mechanical engineer like mine and
so I flagged it in this chapter called
leanytown's typewriter and I thought I
felt that I would come back to it
and so hence about a decade later after
going through many other I think
digressions and detours and many many
archives and delving deep into this and
talking to many people in Industry
because that's what this project took
and that's where we are now
so
let me just go back to this you will see
that the footnote is from an article
that who she wrote I mentioned as a
preface it's a preface to something
called a four corner index system
and it's by a man who was not alone in
his Endeavor so what this meant was when
who should talk about organization just
as in the alphabet he's in dictionaries
that's all organized by ABCD you might
not appreciate the power of the alphabet
but at this incredible
ease and efficiency of self-organization
has meant a lot of different other kinds
of conveniences right you know B never
comes before a you know t comes after s
so this predictability gives an immense
power in simply organizing libraries you
can look up anything in the dictionary
anything in the catalog telephone
directories and even early days of
computing
so
the fact that you just need to learn 26
symbols and then you can construct any
word you want in the English language in
all Indo-European languages out of those
26 symbols it's actually remarkable
now if I can shift you to look at
Chinese characters
there's about eighty thousand depending
on who you ask of course not all of them
are being used at any given time and in
fact for modern day literacy you
probably need three four three to five
thousand characters
still a lot compared to 26. I can tell
you stories of you know one of the
strongest memories growing up is writing
these characters over and over again
like you would get anywhere between 15
to 35 40 of them a day in school and the
bulk of your homework at least back in
the 80s would be to just repeat them
over and over again to commit them to
muscle memory
so
what this man did in four corner index
system was to figure out how to use
characters to give them this kind of
indexical function
and what he proposed was actually let me
just give I had a little bit about
here
is
to put it very simply there he basically
takes parts of characters because you
see the Chinese characters in The
Squarespace so wealthy can divide it up
into four quadrants
and you can use the corner if you
identify the Contour of what the
character looks like in the corner you
assign a number to it so his idea is
that okay there was four numbers you can
tag a character in all four sides and
that will help you zoom in and hone in
on the character that you're looking for
now this is very important because why
else and how else would you look for
characters to fish them out of let's say
80 thousands or thousands
so he was not alone
in this there was chengbong yaw who
wrote The Standard radicals simplified
characters index
there was
look up in 12 character Strokes so this
is from 1920s and 1940s there was a
massive massive race to find What's
called the character retrieval system
the golden key that will lock all these
um all the unlock all these doors
and the list goes on and on
now wonyou was the one that's
highlighted in red but he was not the
only one although the most successful
in fact one of the pleasures of working
on this book is to basically engage with
these human characters behind every
Chinese character that made their
preservation possible
and when you get to know them you
understand why for instance this man
Zhang Fong a young man at the time
had the audacity of perhaps vain hope of
challenging system
at the time was already a publishing
Maverick he was very well connected he
claims to have been an auto died act
taught himself by reading Encyclopedia
Britannica from page to page he got up
at four every morning drank gallons of
water and go on like a brisk walk this
is so he could create a law around
himself so obviously he was also a
marketing Maverick
now John Fong was this young man who
obviously was very smart and he had a
great idea about tagging characters not
by numbers but by looking at its shape
and he organized a kind of simpler
system this way
and so he was all but 20 some years old
he decided he wants to challenge
and he made the mistake one could say in
retrospect by issuing a public challenge
in the newspaper asking him to almost
like a Duo I have no idea what that
would have looked like in real life
I don't know if you throw characters at
each other or pieces of paper at each
other then in case he made that he
issued that challenge
and he did a lot he he carried his
samples he gave them to anyone he could
teach it to he really tried to publicize
but it was only one man right and he
could not possibly defeat the entire
publicity Machinery that one evil had at
his fingertips
because he did something very clever
which was at the time he was a main
editor for the biggest biggest
Publishing House in China commercial
press which is still exists today
and Commercial press put out all these
reference works which is actually not
common prior to 20th century but modern
reference works like dictionary
thesaurus etc etc
and to use any of them
you had to learn Wang yugos for a corner
system
I can tell you the four corner system is
not easy to use
and yet it still persisted when I was in
graduate school at Harvard in um in in
2000s where you can still that's still
how you have to look up certain things
in the old catalog system
was quite successful he basically did
the one thing I think that would bruise
any young ego he just simply ignored
Zhang Fong
and johnful pretty much fell into
anonymity
but his scheme is actually one that won
a lot of I think confirmation much later
on
so what's really at stake when we talk
about characters well
there's also the added external
perception of Chinese characters that
didn't really help didn't really help
highlight this
intrinsically materialist technological
challenge that it posed for the Modern
Age
because if since the 17 actually 16 but
more famously 17th century
Europeans have been fantasizing and
imagining what Chinese writers of
Chinese writing was all about
by the Exotic character here this is a
man anatacio's kirisher who's very well
known he wrote this book China ilustrata
which was publishing in 1667 where he
shows right that character has written
this very ornate way they're so in tune
with nature that they're literally
put together by turtles or bugs if you
can see that you can see that below
and most Europeans who actually had not
traveled abroad
did this just go out is it still let's
do one okay most Europeans who actually
had not traveled abroad took his word
for it and he in turn took other
people's word for it because there were
missionaries who went to China actually
tried to work in the Chinese language on
the ground
but kirscher had particular imagination
about what it was and this type this
kind of imagination or fantasy about the
Chinese language will persist down to
our day
but I just want to point out how
powerful it was that external perception
had begun this other kind of lore about
the Chinese language
and I also want to say as a footnote
that it turns out it was not completely
kircher's imagination he didn't just
pull this out of a hat
because at the time there were certain
books that were translated or actually
brought back to Europe putting libraries
Etc
and one of those books that we are quite
sure he saw
was this particular one which is was
known as a popular almanac at the time
it was almost like a it's hard to
describe what it is but it's sort of a
for Layman popular usage and it was sort
of decorate and kind of exaggerate sort
of Chinese character writing for
decorative purposes largely
and so any Chinese wouldn't take this
seriously as high knowledge but of
course for Europeans who are just kind
of bringing these books back they didn't
really have the context to evaluate
so what kirscher turned out what where
he got it from was simply this very
popular Almanac that is not really part
of the Chinese language Theory
believe that it's in May this
imagination persisted how do you deal
with these thousands tens of thousands
of characters
well
in 1897
the first man first person would try to
put Chinese into a typewriter
what's this Presbyterian American
Presbyterian missionary
so I want to accentuate the fact that
this Chinese language the
technologization of Chinese language was
not just a Chinese Affair it's not just
the Chinese were concerned about it
Outsiders foreigners westerners were
equally concerned because they wanted a
way to break into China into its Market
to win the hearts and minds of his
peoples to proselytize to convert them
Etc et cetera
so Sheffield's answer was
well kind of workmen-like he decides
well of course you need to basically
have a key for every character and you
have a place where every whole character
so he put thousands on what is basically
like a flat disc drum
and to find the care so all the little
dots that you see on it are actually
characters supposed to be characters
and then you sort of Crank that use that
Crane and you somehow line it up with a
needle on top and then do this very
laborious it's basically like a three
four step process but you can imagine a
person who's doing it it's almost like
uh it's almost like rubbing your tummy
and patting your head at the same time
because you have to rotate on one hand
but then also kind of pull it push and
pull with the other it was they're very
physically challenging but Sheffield
kind of meant it that way he said
because you know the physical labor well
teach those lazy people how to actually
remember learn characters yourself on
his own his fellow missionaries right
that they actually have to commit
characters to memory the same one that
Chinese do
but nonetheless it was not a very
imaginative solution
because this was obviously cumbersome
difficult to use even though it seems
like a giant leap forward at the time
because this is what we're dealing with
now this is a a keyboard tray isn't it's
inverted right so you see the characters
in this sort of mirror image
and each of those characters are carved
into these lead slugs
and every time you want to print
something you would take out a tray
we arrange these characters to sort of
just like the way you have it in the
text
and then you use it to print that way
and China actually invented this
technology in the 11th century the
movable type at the time was kind of
made of clay not quite lead
but this technology of literally you
have to carve each character into a slug
and then use it to type and rearrange it
for a text and then do it all over again
to fish them out of you know over
storage and then do it like over and
over again
this was actually a main technique for
printing
up to Mid 20th century
pretty remarkable
was it cumbersome for Chinese yes but
they also found a way around this such
that if you can believe it it was faster
for them to melt down everything at the
end of the day and then recast the next
day
than it is for them to try to locate
locate these characters right so the
main issue really is and who should had
an absolutely write how to select
retrieve and locate characters that was
going to be key to almost everything in
modernization because if you don't
modernize your language nothing else
will be able to
so
that previous image of the the type the
tray of types is actually a close-up of
this typewriter
there's three of them in the United
States three existing
this one is in the museum of Chinese
America in New York City
another ones in the Huntington Library
in Pasadena and the third one we we
believed in private collection
so this is called a shoe style
Chinese typewriter
because this man's shoe actually did not
invent it himself but he built it based
on the model by your previous Chinese
typewriter inventor
after Sheffield in 1897 it was this
young man joho Quinn who actually went
to MIT he's one of these first he's
actually a second class but one of the
first wave of Chinese students who were
sent abroad to study MIT Cornell etc etc
and he was a double major he was the
first actually the first graduate in
Aeronautical Engineering which is a
brand new program MIT at the time Avion
or present to Avionics
and this was also not supposed to be a
senior thesis thesis was about how to
make a bamboo as strong as concrete but
as with my writer limi Tom this was his
passion and he worked on this whenever
he was not working on his homework
so the shoe style Chinese typewriter
works with you see that there's a tray
of slugs right and every time you move
this there's no keyboard that's the
important thing to bear in mind there's
a forest of keys but no keyboard so you
can't really type it you can only kind
of locate it through kind of like
Sheffield's typewriter which Joe Hogan
actually took a lot of inspiration from
recognized that each character would
still have its own slug its own type
that characters cannot be divided up
because he inherited this thinking and
this is true Chinese characters
traditionally had only there's only one
part of it that can be singled out for
inesical purposes but it doesn't quite
fit the purpose of modern needs
so this is the this is the joho Quan the
MIT student
and his solution to a force of keys was
basically he only had a blueprint we
know that he built a typewriter
but he was a star MIT he had job offers
in the United States
but he decided that he would go back to
China
because he had thought
airplanes is not what China needed now
where there's not even cars but if you
could bring back a way of printing
Chinese characters
of mechanizing the Chinese language so
that it can make print and literacy
accessible that would be the one measure
that would be critical to China's
national survival
so my favorite story about this is
actually joho Quinn comes back he goes
at Shanghai where he's from
a Gibbs is very dramatic lecture
it was very quiet it was a very hot
summer night in Shanghai and they were
so hot they were serving ice cream to
attract more crowd
and Johor Quinn showed up he had this
perfectly quaffed hair Western suit
he was obviously he was not I don't
think he was a terribly funny man from
the way he looks pretty serious fellow
he had with him a briefcase
and he carried it up to the podium with
him kind of like where I am he puts it
next to his feet
and just as everyone quieted down he did
this very odd thing
he opened up the briefcase
and took out
what looked like workman's overalls
they pulled it over his suit
and he said
don't be afraid to get your hands dirty
and what did he mean by that
because traditionally manual labor was
looked down upon in China
it's mostly it's there's a reason why
it's a society or civilization built on
literacy and loudness and prized
learning as such
so anyone who worked with a manual labor
like Craftsman it was kind of looked as
kind of sex or carpentry it's really
kind of like secondary it was more like
a skill right it was not knowledge it's
more like skill
but joho Quinn having gone through an
engineering program in the United States
having actually interned in factories
knew that was not the case
and to modernize China had to strengthen
engineering mechanics is scientific
learning and to do that he believed you
had to correct the prejudice against the
kind of modernity and modernization
so it's a very successful night
unfortunately his efforts didn't go very
far
he actually got a job at commercial
Press commercial press the same press we
were talking about
except he couldn't really quite pull it
off
parts that he required for the
typewriter was too expensive and he was
so accustomed to the conditions MIT and
you know in the United States that he
was appalled by the degree of you know
workmanship
right Precision workmanship
he's very frustrated and decided he
would tell commercial press like why
don't you give me money to send me back
to United States
and let me do this there
and the editor at the time who is this
classic Confucian scholar very very
shrewd he's like no no we're not putting
money back in America's pockets
you have to do that here
but he said you know what why don't you
just go
you know what we can just kind of you
know let you be free of our contract
free from the contract
it's very clever because what commercial
press did was they kept the Prototype
and they kept the blueprint of this
typewriter
so Johor actually end up doing fine you
don't have to worry too much about him
but he didn't do much with his
typewriter but then commercial press
decided you know these Ivy League
returnings he's ivy league Webster
educator of attorneys they come back and
they're spoiled and you know they expect
this and that we need someone hungrier
so he found this man shul a young man
who didn't get to go to America for
education and he came back
produce this typewriter
but still that did not quite solve all
the problems
because you're still talking about whole
characters so we're not exactly using
characters like alphabet right you still
can't break it down like the way you can
award into letters so you still have to
deal with the sheer challenge of number
and size
so
amidst all these people all these
inventors and you know Mavericks and
eccentrics because there were many
eccentrics in this race there was
another one
that came to rise above everyone else
that is I'm happy to say my writer
already we see a man who is who I think
is is Born To Be A well-bred and well
liked
and he was actually a famous humorist he
wrote essays he became actually the most
beloved and probably still to date the
most well-known Chinese writer in
America
he was here in the 30s and 40s
so Louis Tong came up with this idea of
a clear and quick typewriter and why is
it clear and quick
he went back and looked at the Chinese
character and realized that remember I
just I told you just a few minutes ago
that Chinese characters you can use one
part called it's actually called a
classifier or radical to identify and do
group characters
he had this idea well why can't you
treat all parts of a character as though
it were Radical
so you basically break down each
character into parts or what he called
components what came to be known as
components
and once you have these components you
can lay them out map them onto an
alphabetic keyboard right like the
QWERTY keyboard we still use
and then you can use that as a way of
combining and recombining characters
so this is actually quite brilliant
because of that turn that that shift in
mentality right leaving Tom managed to
basically map Chinese characters onto
this keyboard
and what you have is the I think the top
two rows top two three rows has the top
components he had this idea even if you
don't know characters at all if you look
at like a character surely you can tell
what's on top and what's on bottom
that's actually all you need because he
broke out these parts into top and
bottoms on the keyboard so that you
select a top key you select the bottom
key you press both keys together
okay it's a little more still a few more
steps but bear with me but then you have
this what's called a magic viewer it's
like a little window a physical window
that pops up
and just through his statistical
analysis it will give you uh anywhere
between five to eight Chinese characters
that fit the bill
and then you visually identify which one
of those five or eight is the character
you have in mind and then you press a
key which is actually where the current
space bar is where you're having a
keyboard space bar he divided that up
into Eight Keys number one through eight
so you just press the corresponding key
so in three steps you can put the
character you want on a piece of paper
it's actually quite extraordinary
because also this is before
this is this is still mechanical age
this is like far before electronic let
alone mechanical or electrical digital
so this was all done with levers and
poles and maximizing what's inside the
wheels and axles it was pretty
extraordinary
and this is what that keyboard looks
like
this is actually from the patent
application that he submitted in the
late 1940s so it was approved I believe
1952.
now
he gives demonstrations again you can
see he's very he's very camera friendly
actually and that's his daughter by the
way who will go to undo these demos with
him
and essentially he said the magic
viewers the one that you see worse or
opens out to the window it's kind of
this cumbersome thing but if you any of
you that might use Chinese characters
when you type you will also notice that
these days when you type in what you
want for you spell the Chinese character
you also get a window right you still
can't just fish out the exact one you
want you get a window of the likely
candidates and you basically have to
like scroll through scroll through
scroll through
that repeatedly comes from leaving
Town's invention
but there's an even bigger deal with
this a kind of backstory and this is how
you know these different histories have
a way of connecting and
getting forgotten and then remembered
again
now leaving town also had a similar
disappointment with his typewriter
because of the problem of mass scaling
so that's been the bottleneck all along
you can create a great prototype but
this comes to okay like how do we build
thousands hundreds not just one or two
and you couldn't find factories that
could do this and the parts because they
all had to be customized was very
expensive
so he eventually sold it to the
mercantileer linotype company
and for they gave them twenty five
thousand dollars for it
but this was also 50s
this was the era of Cold War
cryptography
where machine translation where United
States and the Russian the American
Russians were trying to break into and
intercept each other's messages or you
know using machine to translate you know
automatic translation
and the Chinese language figured a
prominent role in this
so mercantileer
handed it over to actually the United
States Air Force
who then handed over to IBM for further
development
in the summer of 1967 I believe I've had
to check months maybe it was 63
IBM unveiled something called the the
sino-writer
and or it was also it was had a couple
of different names but the Sino writer
basically used liuiton's keyboard the
one you just saw this one
to create basically a prototype that
will lead to later Chinese Computing in
the United States
now this was not the only path because
there was also project at MIT at the
time with this um graphic arts Research
Foundation Garf
based in Cambridge that was also trying
to build kind of First Chinese computer
so to speak
but they too this man Samuel Caldwell
who people thought you know America's
the the I think it's been called he's
been called the father of Chinese
Computing he was an American he didn't
know Chinese and what's also not very
well known is that he also relied on
Louis Toms
um character analysis
because when he was first
um called in to talk about the project
there's I think there was three three
people in the room there was him his his
boss
a third person
who was a Chinese graduate student
PhD who came to work with Caldwell
and he was handed a task of doing a
first survey into the feasibility of
doing something like this and he
basically provided all the Chinese
language know-how to Caldwell
so one reason I really like about
this is one of the many stories that
interweave through Kingdom of characters
is really how something so Niche and so
esoteric and so overlooked could play
such a big role in her globalization and
a global the possibility of China's
presence in the world now because
getting Chinese into Computing was the
door that would open all other doors and
even during cultural revolution this
state very much recognized that and they
had to grit their teeth through
obviously the extremely I think the
extreme conditions of the cultural
revolution but even throughout the
cultural revolution there was always
individuals like Liu Tong like Johor
Quinn who kept that threat going
and to me the Chinese script Revolution
was the true people's Revolution right
and it's the longest most forgotten and
it's not the people as in what is
invoked
um by the Chinese government it is not
the people invoked by the Nationalist
government before that it's really
people from all walks of life you know
the second third stringers of History I
like to say who are neither radical nor
really revolutionary but they were the
ones who picked up the pieces after
every war after every Invasion and to
think about they're the ones who cared
and think about what China is going to
be in the future
so I leave that story here and I'll
welcome any questions
[Applause]
thank you so much for that absolutely
fascinating talk um we have a microphone
that is evolving
oh
my God
we're the young volunteer oh my goodness
relishes
what do I do
is that oh good
so I just want to clarify isang
derived radicals or recognized radically
he was the first
person to recognize radicals and he did
in a particular way in an essay in 1917
so he was a he was a young man no one
really knew exactly who he was really he
wrote These two very unsexy essays for
the time because everybody's talking
about Revolution and you know
vernacularization and overthrowing this
and that he wrote a very modest piece
about Library catalogs Library index
system and then after that he actually
was not part of this race in the 20s and
30s because then he went abroad he went
and got his PhD in Leipzig Germany he
went to Harvard he became a writer but
that opening Salvo everybody else heard
it and so a lot of the inventors in the
book were the ones that kind of followed
his footsteps but then did something new
with it
thank you
I think you just toss it
okay
next question
I'm gonna toss it till I toss it
oh my goodness
so all of that took place before
simplified uh characters I'm so glad I'm
so glad you asked that
um
you know that the history is simple we
think of simplified writing simplified
characters and also romanization pinging
as a twin achievements under Mao in the
50s
but you'd be surprised to know that
simplified characters were proposed way
before them by the nationalists
in as early as 1909
and in the 30s the nationalists were the
ones who proposed well they were the
Iranian government then they proposed a
set of characters to be simplified but
they couldn't push it through for two
reasons China was in the throes of War
right they were just throughout the 20th
century it was just torn by internal
like Civil War
warlordism Revolution for an invasion
one after the other
and the other reason
the other reason is because they had
they met resistance they were these you
know older members the party who
actually had a very dramatic description
one scene where one got down his knees
to tell him leave the Chinese characters
alone you know for them I mean this is
very power resistance is the difficulty
in shifting frame of mind like way of
thinking and they're just saying you
cannot touch anything on the character
like the idea the idea of deforming
Chinese writing system which is
obnoxious to many and unacceptable and
also because historically Chinese
writing has always been equated with
authority there's a whole there's very
few writing system that comes with such
a rich and kind of imposing
philosophical theory about you know its
origin and what it meant
thank you
yes all right
[Music]
uh thanks so much
um I guess my question is building off
that why the 20th century
um like you talk a lot about like who
sure right and like obviously a lot of
early 20th century thinkers and like
their drive to kind of categorize and
like look into Library science and
there's this like focus on the character
and breaking it down
um and you know what I feel like a lot
of people end up learning in Chinese
class is like oh one of the big like
inventions of the first emperor of China
is this character system to unify all
these ethnic groups and um diverse
cultures so I'm kind of curious on
why this drive to like
in this hyper focus on Library science
and categorization in the early 20th
century rather than like earlier
well this is why
argument of the book which is because
what we saw was when language became
infrastructure
because it's not today I gave a story
about Chinese typewriting and Looney
town because he's a writer and I'm a
literature person but a big part of the
book is also about telegraphs and
telegraphy how do you expect to send
a telegram in Chinese if you're using
Morse code which is dots and dashes for
letters and actually numbers too but
letters not character writing so R in
1870s China went through this
extraordinary period of trying to figure
out how to enter itself into air for
telegraphy and at that time it couldn't
take control of its fate because there
is all this competition between actually
the Danes and the British to break it
they had the big telegraphic companies
and interest in breaking into the Far
East
and so the Dangs there's this very
famous episode one moonless night I talk
about this where they basically secretly
snuck onto cables onto Chinese territory
and just built it
despite the Chinese having said no don't
do it and there's a lot of popular
Revolt too against foreigners building
telegraphs because of course some of
these cables go underground in a force
for Chinese this is Blasphemous because
they were digging through ancestral
Graves
and the idea that you would disturb and
and basically
um
defame your your ancestors that way was
just utterly unacceptable so there were
popular revolts on the countryside
against foreign intrusion so telegraphy
became part for intrusion but all this
really is to say it started what can we
we can trace this Opium War right that
forced China to try to figure out what
its standing was vis-a-vis the west but
more importantly you know telegraphy
typewriting Computing these were all
critical
bottlenecks in the history of what's
become the most important thing of our
day which is Global Communications
technology
so China is each step away it was trying
to break into this infrastructure right
but it had to mold itself to an
alphabetic structure because the Western
alphabet had the first mover advantage
and it's impossible in the history
technology you know technology and
science you all you all learn very
quickly that is almost impossible to
break a first mover's Advantage because
a class example is Cordy
I mean I think most people know about
the quarter keyboard where it comes from
why is it you know it's ordered that way
the letters are put next to each other
so to prevent hammers from sticking we
use these really old style typewriters
which I remember my grandmother had when
I was a kid so
you know that's completely useless now
they're using computers we don't use
those clunky typewriters we have in a
long time but that happens it's
ingrained so even though other more
accessible and you know better keyboards
came along the divorce doctor thing it
didn't really matter because people were
habituated so you can imagine how after
thousands and thousands of years of
using a particular writing system
and to shift to figure out how do we
communicate use distance to communicate
with the alphabet it took extraordinary
determination but also
I think
change the willingness to change was
just very very difficult for China to do
right if you imagine Empire on its last
legs in the late 19th century
our sun is this Brave New World they had
learned something called technology
that's why I was just sending students
like Johor abroad because they didn't
have the Techno the technical know-how
so that's what Unleashed all this so we
think why did Library I mean little did
I know that when I started this project
that library of science would be the one
thing I spent a lot of time with or that
my favorite character in the book is
actually the librarian in chapter four
who called himself Bismarck do because
he wanted to rule the field of Library
science with an iron fist
so there's these you know these
extraordinary stories I think the
individuals because it's not often the
state the Chinese Nation who's competing
it wasn't like that China was in such
disarray in the early 20s you know
throughout the 20th century so much loss
of lives so much displacement it really
is that's why it's all the more
remarkable that in those
in those dark times and there's some
very dark times what I believe kept some
of these what inspired my innovators and
these individuals is precisely that the
light at the end of the tunnel it was
something they could hold on to
something they could save right
something they possessed because it was
language
and they felt that if they do what they
could
they may help one day to contribute to
China's rise
how Google got its start their first
proposal to NSF was a library
classification and the search engine
really came out of that yeah so it's
kind of interesting how all these Loops
go back and forth to classification of
information it really rules the world
right even now and knowledge becomes so
important our times they think about
Wikipedia or how it acts like knowledge
base and the idea of linking knowledge
base if China did not if China did not
make that step and get itself in a
digital age
none of what it is now will be possible
at all
thank you for this talk I was really
fascinated by the new tongues typewriter
method when you brought it up and then I
went through this process of thought I
was like oh yeah I know what that is
wait a minute I don't know how to type
Chinese I want to know what that is
because I used it in Korean and Japanese
but there's a different approach of
course you type it out phonetically
first and you don't like there's a but
you still use Chinese but now we use
right now we use basically alphabet
letters yeah in Chinese yeah I've heard
but in China like you still see these
keyboards because think of it this way
if if you can break down Chinese into
what turns out to be two to four
components every character can be broken
down to either like they get from
anywhere from two to four components
that means two to four keystrokes
to make a character
there are a lot of English words that
are not just four letters right so in
some ways you can type faster right
typing Chinese faster on alphabetic
keyboard so it's this remarkable you
know outcome of being able to harness
alphabetic technology and make Chinese
better right so instead of just becoming
completely hostile alphabetized which
China could have it could just go with
the romanization system we have now but
it's precisely because of the will
passion devotion of people that I talk
about that that character writing lived
on and I was wondering though with
Korean and Japanese
familiar you are with like the history
of this but because they have their own
challenges of course to making up
uh mechanical and then computerized
typewriting differently than writing in
other languages but do you know if they
like all can just happen to converge on
that system where like because when I
type in Korean I type up phonetically if
I want to make a hanja a Chinese
character it will be a numbered list and
I can like hit the number and get the
one I want the sort of turn that
phonetic character phonetic block into a
Chinese character in similar in Japanese
do you know what this is all is like
they were all looking to China and this
all literally traces back to the new
tongue or it was just just convergent
evolution on like what worked best like
some like miraculously I'm glad you
asked that question because sometimes I
get like a you know grumbles from Japan
knowledges who say I don't give enough
credit to Japan because Japan of course
have been using Chinese characters as
part of their three writing systems and
in fact early Japanese typewriters were
also used as references but there's one
critical difference which China will
make this argument again and again
throughout the 20th century Japan only
has a relatively small number of
characters that he uses China only uses
characters so you know it's like this
classic you know this classic saying we
talk about China Size Matters right so
can it use can it scale up technology in
Japan for its own use not quite it
needed something more expedient more in
competency that's also more affordable
right I'm glad you brought that up
because there's definitely a lot of
intro you know like intra-regional
quibbles that I won't I won't talk about
now but they're as good as that
Challenger that young Challenger I told
you about
next
I don't think I can throw it though
[Music]
there
you go
[Music]
um thank you I was really interested
when you mentioned the like
neuroscientific differences between
phonetic languages or not like
alphabetic languages and I do graphic
ones and I was wondering with pinging
and like more phoneticization when you
do like character input and typing does
that change the way people learn Chinese
and the way it's like represented in the
mind
uh that's a very good question I would
have to refer you to the neuroscientists
but who may pursue this at greater depth
I mean I think but what you point out
something very valid is that we interact
with writing a language differently now
it's not just I think we're very close
to bypassing keyboard right because it's
so much about voice input activation and
AI technology is really going to change
a lot of that so you know one might also
ask whether you know this entire Century
right or actually 400 years of
modernizing Chinese to the alphabetic
infrastructure it brought us to a point
where possibly their efforts are now
completely you know absorbed into that
progress right
hi I had um a related question about
neuroscience and I wondered if there's
been any studies about brain use with a
character language versus a letter
language because it makes me think you
know people are always being told do
crossword puzzles or we you know all
kinds of puzzles to stretch your brain
and I'm thinking someone who learns 5
000 patterns essentially that they can
recognize versus someone who has 26
things
it just seems like their brain the
character brain would be stretched from
the outset and I just wonder if there
was any brain science on that there's a
couple of people that you should read
and they really want I consulted I had
the pleasure of Consulting them both one
is marchangisi you can find this boy I
think visual Revolution both came out in
2010 the other one is stunicious to hang
was it who's based in Paris but I was
having a personal anecdote to that so
when I read Chinese
I can read it very very quickly
and a lot of times I don't read
character by character at all
is I can actually scan a page and kind
of tell what the content is just because
that visual patterning has become so
familiar to me
when I read English I can't read it the
same way I can read it fast but still
kind of like you know scanning fast I
can't just kind of as a as they say kind
of like just kind of like I can't just
shine I can just shoot a glance at it as
though I'm just shining a spotlight on
the page and get like a gist
approximately what's what's the content
yeah
um
so I think there was somebody there
I can talk loud
thank you so much
thank you for the wonderful inspiring
game talk um I wanted to know what the
emergence of this technology did to the
art of handwriting whether as an art
form or um on daily basis to various
Generations who were I I assume as it
was the case
um in the Middle East that was a very
pressure and beautiful art form and we
can see it in our family history is how
our writing kind of degenerated from one
generation to another I'm so glad you
asked that because it's very common with
every technological innovation there's a
lament a Nostalgia for something that's
gonna be lost
and it's clear that certainly I know my
handwriting has deteriorated this age
but I think and I think that's a very
general lament as echoed
I go by Educators around the world but I
think the digital air has also brought
us something more right so I do think it
is true that some art will be lost just
as when we look back there are many
customs and practices and art forms
Associates writing that we don't even
use even like poetry
Chinese literate used to write verse
whenever they see a friend when they
have Jinx together they can just Dash up
a verse like that for us it would be
something you probably have to work at
for two months if not longer right so I
do think those habits technology changes
with with technology does change I think
what we consider to be art but I think
it's also challenging more importantly
what Innovation means and what
creativity means right I'm personally
very interested idea of you know this
new literacy provided by the Google is
it the wikipedias like what does it come
down to for knowledge is kind of
gradually replaced by information
and that there's not a place where
wisdom and experience because everything
as in Wiki in the Wikipedia it means
quick in Hawaiian which is where it's
from like as in the wiki wiki bus if you
ever
they're open to Hawaii and take that bus
from the airport
um so you know it's it's we have a
completely different relationship to
what it means to know
it's about what's at my fingertips
what's the first two searched you know
this first three things that might come
up when I search for something and I
think that's actually terribly
frightening because I certainly know
that as a scholar as a human a scholar
My Greatest Inspiration is to wonder
through stacks and find that accidental
book that's not someone misshelved and
kind of takes me on a different kind of
Association associational process
thinking process but now that
associational process has been done for
you and they try to generate Randomness
into it but that Randomness where it's
almost like we're not working for it
we're just like typing it in letting the
algorithm do it so I do think it's a
kind of a strange leveling process and
frankly as a teacher I know preo feels
the same I don't know what it means for
a future generation
um but I had a quick question if I may
um you know so how did this impact so
the artistic tradition of calligraphy
was that really considered as sort of
high culture and sort of a separate
question uh sort of insulated from all
this sort of experimentation with
um the characters
well it's interesting to say that
because it also has to do with how do
you preserve calligraphy which is so
highly stylized and individualized right
it's almost like your signatures you're
like your your fingerprint and how that
would enter the digital age means how to
represent it in font right in fonts now
we talk about fonts you know helvetica
you know garamond is ones that you you
see I use um calibri I think but you
won't believe this I mean you might now
that you've heard this talk but in China
font design is huge and they have
managed to design these you know really
funky fonts all over so much so that
last year I believe was last year before
um the government issued a a restriction
in monitoring people because as you know
these are just done by like you know
moving vectors you know dragging this
and that using software it's not done
through real practice of calligraphy
right people are just randomly fattening
up this character in the different like
as it was done like a particular hand
writing but it's all just computer
generated so there's actually kind of
just as you know China is a hyper I
think techno technology friendly country
but at the same time remember it's it's
it can do both and
it can understand the good of
modernization
westernization technology but it also
recognizes that a way how it got itself
this far was to preserve its cultural
identity and its cultural core
you know colonialism
it has had its advantages in terms of
you know Indians learning how to speak
English and joining the Western World
much more seamlessly but it's
interesting that the British colonial
um
infrastructure did not get rid of sort
of the Chinese this imposition of the
English the alphabet and the language
didn't have as much of a success you
know China watched very closely it
always said what was happening India
um Persia country civilization that lost
their language when they became
colonized so you you have to understand
that this is still you know when you
hear now in the headlines like when
China accuses you know toss West
imperialism American imperialism it's
not just rhetoric right it's very it has
basically ingrained this way of thinking
that this is the one thing right that it
must guard itself against and it goes
back it goes way back it's not just the
past 60 years
we have time for maybe one more question
if anybody wants to ask
uh hi professor I have a rather
technical question for um
about Lincoln Town's typewriter so so
you mentioned that you have to press two
keys together for the two parts but
there's a lot of characters that don't
have two parts they're just just one
piece and so how do you do with that so
what he recognized and thank you for
that question is that it's not so much
you divide them to two parts you need to
just identify the top
Contour
and the bottom Contour
so it doesn't necessarily it's kind of
like the four corner system where you
kind of identify shape it's shape based
so it's not necessarily true that you
can only share similar Parts because
that would still be a very unmanageable
number
but for instance if your top part is a
stroke across
many characters have that as a starting
stroke right and same with the bottom
stroke what sort of starts it so he
actually makes it more Elemental than
just looking at in terms of components I
see then okay I guess why I use top and
bottom instead of that one right sorry
white top and bottom instead of left and
right
statistically that's how he figured it
out that is actually not what we think
of as in you know like two parts side by
side which is accounts for like top and
bottom and side-by-side counts with
majority shape pattern of Chinese
character writing but he figured out
that the top bottom is the easiest for
his purpose which is all the more
extraordinary like how he arrived at
this right
sorry
he was a first mover but then you know
he's there there have been so many
others it's really a collective effort
it feels like people are indebted to him
but they have also gone beyond him but
nonetheless yeah that was the opening
Salvo
um at this point Let's uh thank you
again for this fantastic talk thank you
for having me
[Applause]
[Music]